[Musique]
nicolas bûcher bonjour merci d'être sur
le plateau de tv 70 gîte pour ce vip que
l'on va entièrement vous consacrez vous
êtes ici qu'à vous êtes le directeur
depuis mars 2018 du cmbv le centre de
musique baroque de versailles
c'est cela jusqu'à tout va bien alors il
se passe plein de choses et on va en
parler le plus vite possible parce qu'il
ya plein de choses à dire déjà vous on
aimerait apprendre un petit peu qui vous
êtes vous êtes vous avez une formation
je crois d'organiste vous avez démarré à
arras j'ai démarré sur mes terres
natales effectivement dans le dans le
pas de calais lens et arras est
effectivement moi mais seules études et
mais seul diplôme sérieuses ont des
diplômes d'organiste travers mais très
sérieux vous avez un premier prix
d'orgue au conservatoire royal de
bruxelles voile à bruxelles après à lyon
pour mes études et puis mon plus haut
fait d'armes on va dire c'est un
concours international au japon que j'ai
gagné en octobre 2001 un concours de
donc d'orques
voilà ça c'est vraiment votre camp des
spécialités évidemment après vous avez
aussi accès votre carrière vers la
direction de centres musicaux peut dire
ça oui vous avez été à voit pas tout
dire parce que c'est vrai mais j'ai
plusieurs conservatoires à laquelle il
ya
dizaine d'années on va là très aussi
bien des petits des moyens des gros et
puis à 10 ans j'ai un petit peu changé
de voie pour diriger un centre culturel
dans l'yonne avait gelé au pied de la
très célèbre basilique de vézelay et où
j'ai travaillé là pendant sept ans et
vous allez créer là un lieu qui
s'appelle la cité de la voie qu'il ya un
lieu de résidence pour des artistes dans
ce lieu absolument magnifique qui le
désole la bourgogne du nord n'a craint
donc c'était complètement dédié au chant
lyrique
voilà c'était un endroit dédié au chant
choral au chant lyrique enfin tout tout
ce qu'on peut faire avec sa joie ou
presque voilà et qui était à la fois un
lieu de résidence un ensemble vocal
professionnel est un festival qui existe
toujours qui maintient qui s'appelle les
rencontres musicales de vestiges très
bien d'accord donc ça alors on mars 18
vous êtes vous avez quitté vézelay voilà
pour versailles exactement tous qu'avec
un v toujours voilà je vais lever mon
coeur bat écoute et pourquoi pas et donc
vous êtes le directeur et vous avez
comme on dire plusieurs mois déjà
non je sais ce qu'on va dire on va dire
où se trouve ce centre de musique
baroque à versailles c'est avec paris on
sa venue exactement 22 avenue de paris
donc dans cette grande avenue qui
conduit au château on est à peu près
entre 700 mètres et un kilomètre du
château est donc en fait on est dans des
locaux qui appartiennent au château on
est un établissement partenaire du
château mais on a une forme
d'indépendance sont aussi structurelles
vis-à-vis du château d'accord et c'est
pas dans un petit
dix neuf les moches que vous êtes n'ont
pas tout à fait un très bel hôtel
particulier en fait qui est l hôtel des
menus plaisirs qui porta aussi un très
très beau non oui et 7 hôtels des menus
plaisirs a été construit sous louis 15
pour justement abriter les décors et
l'administration des menus plaisirs et
donc entre autres des spectacles du
temps de la cour à versailles théâtre
opéra spectacles musicaux etc et donc il
al'avantage d'être très grand cet hôtel
déjà lanka natal
d'ailleurs en 1789 les états généraux en
ont profité pour installer leur leur
état en septembre leur réunion etc
et après c'est tombé un peu c'est aller
un peu du côté des militaires je crois
moi la réponse est présent mais pas une
occupation militaire entre guillemets et
puis ça a été aussi le lieu des services
techniques de la ville de versailles
pendant quelque 175 ch
voilà exactement et puis à partir de
cette période là une période aussi de
prise de conscience du patrimoine
façon générale au niveau national et
c'est avec la création du centre de
musique baroque de versailles en 87 que
très rapidement en fait le ministère de
la culture s'est dit mais pourquoi ne
pas ré attribuées aux musiques baroque
de versailles en première voilà
exactement et c'est comme ça que l'hôtel
des menus plaisirs a été restaurée à
l'occasion du bicentenaire de la
révolution en 1989
voilà pourrez vous y allez en 96 96
voilà dans cet accord qui sont
magnifiques et qui sont pas tout à fait
ouverts au public mais sur lequel on est
ravis d'accueillir des gens pour montrer
ces lieux il sait comme personne qui
travaille à peu près en une cinquantaine
cinquantaine d'accords très bien alors
maintenant on va passer aux missions qui
vous anime
il y en a plusieurs alors déjà la
formation où l'action culturelle
peut-être oui avec moi l'information on
travaille avec un choeur d'enfants et
d'adultes s'appelle qui s'appelle la
maîtrise et les enfants s'appellent les
pages et les adultes s'appelle les
chantres un dac est donc l'ensemble fait
un coeur qui s'appelle les pages et les
chantres et c'est une formation en fête
qui pour les enfants est ouverte à
partir de l'âge de 4 5 ans environ déjà
oui exactement vous avez des enfants de
4 ans qui chante avec des adultes de 30
ans non les enfants viennent au jardin
musical
oui c'est le moment de la découverte à
corps et à partir de environs du ce1 ce2
les enfants peuvent rentrer dans un
processus d'horaires aménagés c'est à
dire en gros oui
le matin ils sont à l'école et l'après
midi ils sont en répétition de musicale
très bon formation musicale avec à la
maîtrise vous avez un partenariat avec
des écoles pour ça voilà avec l'école va
plaire et avec le collège rameau pour
les collégiens pour les collégiens
d'accord exactement et tout ça nous
emmène jusqu'à la fin de la quatrième ou
de la troisième dépens et donc ça c'est
la formation pour les enfants toutes les
après midi ils sont quasiment ils sont
en formation l'agent et s'est ouvert à
n'importe quel enfant faut passer une
audition mais c'est une addition pour
voir si la voix est saine pour
voir si l'enfant est saine si la voix
est saine voilà c est là bas si la voix
est pas cassé ou si elle n'est pas
abîmée et quatre ans ça peut arriver ça
peut arriver à tous à tout âge très bien
et mais le principal c'est d'avoir envie
de changer cet accord et à partir de
quel âge on a quel âge on peut avoir
quand on démarre la maîtrise le coeur
des pages et des champions donc le mieux
c'est d'arriver assez tôt entre
guillemets parce que justement le plus
plu la formation commence tôt plus plus
l'enfant est imprégnée de danse c'est
qu'on a créés et voilà en gros comme on
arrive au cours du primaire mieux mieux
s'aimer sa formation de l'enfant et son
intégration à faire alors donc ça c'est
tout ce qui est donc formation vous
formez aussi des chanteurs
professionnels exactement les adultes
car les chancres ils sont là en général
pour deux à trois ans en général de
trois ans et ils viennent alors ils ont
entre 18 et 30 ans et des des adultes
qui ont déjà un parcours de chant
préalable et puis qui voilà qui arrive
50 non voilà et qui arrive dans le but
de devenir chanteur professionnel
et avec un taux d'insertion
professionnelle qui est de l'ordre de
98% une bonne maison très bien bravo
après vous faites aussi de la recherche
oui alors on t'a laboratoire de
musicologie exactement pour la tour de
musicologie ça veut dire prendre à des
chercheurs qui travaillent dans la
maison et qui vient alors ils cherchent
des partitions ils cherchent sur la
manière dont on joue et les partitions à
l'époque il cherche la biographie des
musiciens la biographie des compositeurs
mais aussi la biographie des interprètes
puisque on connaît grosso modo ce qui se
passait mais il ya plein de détails qui
sont extrêmement intéressants en voilà
une photo assez intéressante peut-être
la photo précédente
voilà vous voyez la reconstitution des
violons qui sont des violons très
spéciaux envoyé cinq extrêmement vous
dites voilà déjà en attendant les
annonces très les avons construit à
dessein vous voyez sur cette photo sont
des très très grand violon qui se joue
pas sur la poitrine et pas sous le
menton et c'est un des exemples de
travail de recherche
c'est d'essayer de retrouver la manière
dont on a joué la musique à l'époque
dont quelque chose essentielle à
retrouver c'est la musique et la manière
dont on a joué et d'entraînement voilà
et donc il faut des chercheurs pour
faire ça et notre maison est vraiment un
des centres importants de recherche à ce
niveau là dans le monde et il faut aussi
la connexion avec les musiciens et les
interprètes pour une fois qu'on a la
musique et des pistes d'interprétation
il faut expérimenter il faut essayer
tout ça et pour avoir un résultat
artistique musical puisque le but du jeu
c'est d'entendre de la musique c'est pas
seulement donc de faire un travail de
bibliothèque ou d'édition même si c'est
extrêmement que vous faites aussi
d'ailleurs ce qu'ont fait également
parce que la maison est une maison
d'édition les éditions de samedi
vous avez toute une partie production
aussi qui est très importante
voilà exactement etc tacler le contrant
le résultat ce travail assure amis
tout ce travail de l'ombre qui est très
intense qui est très très précis et
qu'après il faut mettre en musique dans
le tous les sens du terme et qu'il faut
donner entendre au public et à
l'ensemble des gens qui s'intéressent à
la musique est alors est-ce qu'il faut
une voix au niveau des tessitures vous
avez je pensais aux castrats par exemple
bon il ya des voix qui s'apparente un
peu au gré des castrats au lieu exact
exactement en fait toutes les voies
existent oui dans vous en privez pas
voilà et après en fonction des origines
géographiques et de l'histoire il ya eu
des choses plus ou moins
plus ou moins précises ou développé par
exemple vous vous parlez des castrats
les cas sera c'est un phénomène
essentiellement italien c'était une mode
italienne aux xviie et au xviiie siècle
plus tôt 18e d'ailleurs et en france on
a eu très peu de castrats c'était
presque des curiosités le castrat en
france par contre la france a développé
un registre très spécial que la haute
contre et qui est une voix de ténor
léger mais une voix de ténor qui montre
très très haut dans l'aigu et en fait ça
c'est une des spécificités françaises au
niveau vocal a dit barak c'est vous en
avez j'imagine dans votre coeur voilà un
enfant mais on est un des rares endroits
travail oui mais ça se travaille
le secteur tout ce tralala voix c'est
quelque chose qui se travaille il faut
du talent un petit peu de chance et
beaucoup de travail comme dakhla très
bien alors si on veut
si on s'intéresse si on a envie de
découvrir le baroque là il ya un
engouement je trouve depuis 15-20 ans
pour le baroque qui était un peu tombé
en désuétude du avant 1950
we pray en thouy à peu près c'est à la
mode passée en tout cas c'est mine de
rien oui ça fait 40 ans qu'on est dans
une redécouverte mais même pas seulement
du barreau qui c'est à dire aussi du
mets de la musique médiévale de la
musique de la renaissance c'est à dire
depuis une quarantaine d'années le
spectre
des musiques que le public écoute en
général s'est considérablement élargi et
ça c'est une bonne chance sur la
diversité les esthétiques et est
importante et nous ce qu'on promeut par
notre mission c'est effectivement
comment on peut promouvoir la musique
française des xviie et xviiie siècles
qui a une certaine forme d'unité et qui
est le baroque
effectivement alors voilà on va mettre
le baroque à toutes les soins à toutes
les sauces et mais c'est clair que c'est
une esthétique un style qui est
clairement reconnaissable et qui est
homogène et qui est notre style
nationale à nous pendant cette période
et pendant la période versaillaise
principalement la corde ce qu'on voit à
l'écran la 7è suppléments on dire de moi
et c'est un spectacle que le centre de
musique baroque de versailles avait
avait produit j'aime bien cette photo
parce qu'elle montre que le baroque
c'est pas toujours ce qu'on pense comme
ça
bah ça c'est on voit que c'est un
mélange c'est à dire vous voyez il n'y a
pas de perruque
il n'y a pas des hôtes allons enfin on
n'a pas l'impression d'être dans une
reconstitution un peu factice de la cour
de versailles
c'est à dire qu'on voit très bien que le
scénographe s'est inspiré du baroque le
personnage est maquillée très blanc
comme on aimait beaucoup à l'époque on
voit que le costume est plutôt inspiré
du baroque mais on voit que la
scénographie et assez moderne et donc
c'est ça aussi qu'on veut promouvoir
c'est de dire notre nous notre trip
c'est pas la reconstitution historique
pour le plaisir de reconstitution
historique sait comment à partir
justement d'un travail de recherche
comment à partir d'un travail historique
on fait de la musique pour les gens qui
vivent en 2019 et y voilà d'accord alors
ces fameux jeudis musicaux dont je
voulais parler ont lieu à partir du 7
novembre
et ça permet donc à qui veut de
découvrir le baroque en soi et le
travail delà du week end voilà nekrif en
fait tous les jeudis musicaux ça permet
de découvrir plein de choses et
j'encourage tous les yvelinois arnaud
vendre visite là dessus c'est que le
tous les jeudis de l'année scolaire en
gros 2 à partir du 7 novembre à 17h30
c'est un concert qui dure entre 45
minutes et une heure qu'ils aient gagné
qui est gratuit qui est donné
généralement par la maîtrise ou par des
ensembles qu'on invite de temps en temps
aussi pour pouvoir y ait un petit peu
les choses et ça permet de découvrir la
musique ça permet de découvrir ce qu'est
un choeur d'enfants et un choeur
d'adultes ça permet de découvrir la
chapelle de
royal du château que tout le monde là où
ça y est voilà la découvrir gratuitement
aussi et voilà ça permet de découvrir de
découvrir un petit peu d'orgue aussi
tiens puisqu'on entend toujours un petit
peu d'or par les élèves du conservatoire
de paris
bref c'est un moment très particulier
très sympathique c'est assez court pour
pour être justement un bon moment de
découverte et sa gratuité est là pour ça
aussi c'est à dire pour vraiment pour
rendre ce moment accessible
c'est ce qu'on voit là alors ça c'est ce
qu'on voit c'est à budapest chapelle
royale de versailles mais voilà c'est un
très bon moment c'est ça montre 7,7
images illustrent les partenariats
internationaux que l'accord de musique
de baroque de versailles a est ici en
l'occurrence et es11 opérant aux
conserves qu'on a faits au palais de
home upa qui est le la salle des
concerts de budapest d'accord alors ce
qui va se passer bientôt ce sont des
partenariats avec des villes comme trope
pour re dit mon association avec les
jeunes toujours en gros pour dans les
yvelines où on va on a deux beaux
projets qui commence et qui vont durer
au moins pour cette année scolaire voire
l'année voire sur plusieurs années même
avis un projet à houdan où on a une
jeune claveciniste brillantissime qui
s'appelle maryvonne rhein qui va être en
résidence à houdan et autour d'houdan
pendant toute l'année elle va faire
plusieurs séquences laval ont rencontré
des collégiens des lycéens mais aussi de
tout public donc ça va être une année
assez riche et à la découverte d'une
jeune interprète parce qu'il ya des
jeunes interprètes de 25 ans qui joue du
crin-crin professionnellement et qui les
instruments voilà exactement et qui
partage sa avec tous les publics donc on
donne rendez-vous à houdan ça va
commencer à partir du 3 octobre mais ça
va s'étaler sur toute l'année scolaire
et puis après le succès d'un projet qui
s'appelait génération le lit on commence
un nouveau projet attrapé à la verrière
avec plein de gens très différents aussi
bien des scolaires mais aussi des jeunes
voilà on voit où on est
et à la chapelle royale avec des petits
trappistes et on avait invité pour une
visite au château et une visite au
centre et qui est des jeunes qui était
inséré dans le projet génération langue
il faut chanter puis ils ont chanté
exactement et donc trappe et la verrière
vont être concernés par ce beau projet
la fontaine qui va s'étaler sur deux ans
dont quatre antennes la fontaine ça veut
dire que vous allez prendre des fables
nous ça veut dire qu'on va partir du
répertoire des femmes qui ne sont pas
qui n'est pas répertoire chanté mais on
s'est dit que pour pouvoir parler de la
musique baroque on pouvait parler de
aussi des auteurs baroque et de parler
de tout ce qui est contemporain de la
mic on défend notre musique elle est
très belle on aime beaucoup et si on
veut la partager il faut aussi pouvoir
la raccrocher à ce qu'il fait déjà notre
fonds commun de société et les fables de
la fontaine nous ont semblé être un bon
endroit et parce qu'elles disent plein
de choses de plein de manières
différentes quoi
et donc voilà ça c'est les choses
importantes on donne rendez vous donc au
jeu des musiques ou canton alain et puis
à
on aura sur la table excusez moi je vous
coupe que vois-je
vous voyez les céder dans les derniers
start i voilà selon le dernier sorti on
en sort à peu près une dizaine par an on
va et on va les montrer cela montre les
montrez moi
alors vous voyez le sang sortait combien
vous m'avez dit on n'en a pas prêt on a
une dizaine de partenariat parents qui
débouche sur des sur des cd exactement
donc celui qui est dont on voit bien le
nom grands motets en offrant celui là
exactement c'est la dernière réalisation
justement des enfants et des adultes
noté c'est une c'est pas grave
c'est une pièce de musique sacrée avec
un chanter c'est les grands mots tcd
grande pièce qui dure à peu près 20
minutes etc ont chanté pendant les
offices religieux à l'époque
et donc voilà ça c'est assez d enfance
et les pages et les chantres c'est la
maîtrise dont on parlait tout à l'heure
qui existe au moins un cd par an et puis
l'autre cd que vous allez dans la main
tarare c'est le opéra de salieri qui est
très célèbre puisque c'était le sait
lire et le compositeur soi-disant maudit
avec mozart en fait la belle voilà la
réalité complètement différente dans sa
vérité un grand compositeur qui a
composé d opéra en français aussi c'est
assez drôle six italiens qui s'occupe de
la musique baroque
c'est vrai que ce disque est soutenue
outre la musique d'ailleurs en général
qui viennent en france l'approprier ella
ella confère à leur tête c'est super
pouvoir voire même voir monaco
elle a créé oui je sais exactement et
vous vous créez vous sortez a cédé
bientôt moi je suis en pleine période de
post production de ce cd qui sortira au
mois de février 2020 consacré à la
musique française baroque un compositeur
français l'union pas et alien de reims
qui s'appelle de génie mais avec un y
est vous allez jouer ses oeuvres voilà
une intégrale de ses offres d'accord
doit céder qui sort mais février 2000 20
février 2020 super bah écoutez bravo
pour toute cette bande g ration
magnifique de deux projets cette
richesse et tous ces partages de deux
cultures donc janvier vous dit rendez
vous jeudi 7 novembre à 17h30
voilà pour les jeudis musicaux merci
nicolas bûcher le nutella et à très
bientôt j'espère
[Musique]